so there was a man named Benjamin day
who I called the first the attention
merchants the founder of the New York
Sun who was in his own way a business
genius and an innovator he had this idea
which was as opposed to selling a
newspaper for six cents which was the
normal way of doing it he would sell his
newspaper for a penny and try and
attract an enormous audience and resell
that audience to advertisers so the
newspapers at the time the sixpenny
papers were no boring they covered
politics and finance they didn't have
crime stories that kind of thing and he
introduced a sort of far more
interesting newspaper the very first
issue was all about the suicide of a man
who'd been separated from his lover it
had stories of death mayhem destruction
gossip and was sold at such a low price
that he managed to attract these
enormous audiences which then were
resold to advertisers now the thing
about that penny price is it was a money
losing proposition unless he sold enough
and unless he reached enough advertisers
to make it worth it so he pioneered this
unusual business model which today is
found in as many places as Google
Facebook Instagram you know it's sort of
taken over our lives so we are in a
period where there is something of a
revolt going on against advertising
there are a lot of people who consider
themselves immune to ads or try and
avoid all advertisers advertising
there's cord cutters and there's a lot
of people who use ad blocking
technologies to try and have themselves
sort of in an ad-free zone and you know
let's reach the point where it's a
little bit of a kind of a war maybe a
war of attrition now I'll say two things
about that first in the history of
advertising there have been similar
moments seems that about every 30 years
or so there's a kind of revolt usually
because things have gone too far in one
way or another and I think in some ways
things have gone too far on the web that
there is just too much too intrusive too
much privacy invasion and people are
starting to say you know this is
what I bargained for you know we've
whatever deal we had I think you're
exceeding the terms I think that
hopefully it'll lead to a place where we
strike some kind of new deal some kind
of understanding is made you know the
web lacks any kind of limits as to where
advertising should or shouldn't go it's
not like newspapers or something where
there was you know you don't have every
page in the newspaper completely covered
in ads there's kind of a bargain and I
hope we reach that on the web another
thing that it will probably lead to
however is also more and more efforts to
use advertising that is surreptitious
that gets under the radar that you don't
really realize as advertising you might
even call it manipulation or nudges I
think you'll see this particularly with
some of our devices or new technologies
let's say you use Google Maps trying to
find something a place to eat how much
of that decision is based on you know
what's nearby and the best how much it
is based on who is paid Google to sort
of put the ad there I think as we move
into an era where we increasingly rely
on intelligent intermediaries to find
things for us or to be our guides in
life the possibilities of surreptitious
marketing increase and I think that's a
direction that will probably see
particularly with so much resistance to
advertising you know I think as a
culture we've become obsessed with free
stuff almost factly quite to our
detriment you know it's almost
impossible for many people to consider
using anything on the web that isn't
free somehow it's like an outrage if you
have to pay for it and there's been a
cost to that I think that when many
people signed up for you know Facebook
in the early days it just seemed fun and
free there was very few advertising but
slowly or very little advertising but
slowly we've come to understand that
you're paying in very different ways
you're paying with your data
would you hand over you're paying with
your attention you know if you spend I
don't know how many minutes or even
hours a day on Facebook you're giving
over something of tremendous
value and ultimately there's several
ways in which we're paying first of all
we are granting unprecedented levels of
access to ourselves to our portal of
judgment which ultimately has commercial
influence or can influence our life in
other ways so we may without realizing
it end up living lives that are a little
different than we might have wanted to
buying more things and we expect it to
voting for people we might not have
thought we would all these sorts of
things we make ourselves open to
influence let's just put it that way and
the other cost is that ad-supported
mediums have a constant need to deliver
a receptive audience and since we are
the audience we are increasingly
programmed to be more receptive
which means open to distraction ready to
be see something constantly clicking and
looking there's an effect that I call
the casino effect which I think comes to
describe our lives on the web where you
sit down to write an email and then
suddenly you notice four hours have gone
by you're not quite sure what happened
you do know you clicked on a bunch of
stuff and you went here and you went
there and I think that is kind of
becoming our lives and that's a very
attractive mental state for advertisers
because you're constantly clicking
constantly refreshing constantly seeing
new stuff whether it's good for us is an
entirely different question and so I
think we're at risk of losing some of
our ability to deeply focus you know to
get work done to have the kind of
attention span you need to do more
profound kinds of work and that I think
is some of the cost of free so one of
the inspirations for this book was the
philosopher William James who was one of
the first psychologists writing in the
19th century and he had this one line
that really struck me where he said
roughly know your life experience is
what you choose to direct your attention
to and so you know at the end of your
days when it's all said and done what
your life was
we'll be the culmination of what you
paid attention to you know and that
that's in some very profound way true
and it does suggest something
interesting about our times we live in a
time where our life experience moment a
moment is more intermediated than any
other time in human history
it's almost we like we live in a built
environment of attention most I don't
know exactly how you count the hours but
many of our hours are screened as
opposed to physical I mean the screen is
physical but it's some virtual thing and
in some sense we live in a cocoon almost
a projection at this point you know
we're still here but we in terms of what
our attention is paid to a lot of it is
not here and so I think that whether
that's good or bad I'll leave to one
side but it certainly makes it important
that we understand the motives of those
who are creating the cocoon that you're
living in if we are living in kind of a
simulated reality that's where we are
virtual reality is just the stronger
version of it better pretty profoundly
trust who's creating your reality for
you and maybe have some saying in in
what that reality looks like and I
worried a part of the reason I wrote
this book is to examine those
motivations and if it is fundamentally
the motivation to gather you up for
resale to something well that might not
actually be in your interest or you know
sort of suddenly manipulate you in
different ways but even more profoundly
than being sold to which you know is
kind of annoying there is this issue of
living your own life making decisions
which are yours and I don't care if you
listen to the founders or John Stuart
Mill the or if you're a religious person
but the importance of decisions that are
truly ours is so fundamental so profound
to a realized life that I think we need
in this day and age
or so much that we're exposed to is
motivated by other ideas need to be very
careful about reserving time and space
for ourselves and making decisions which
we can truly call our own in order to
live a life you can truly call you
around